okay well that I mean listen I don't I
didn't see that but I've been dealing
with just you know I mean there's like
III guess my thing my big thing that I
don't like doing this thing where I just
like criticize the left from the left
for clicks I think that there's
legitimate stuff to criticize the left
for and one of those things is just like
the narcissism of small differences it's
as it's called we're like we agree on
95% of stuff and we make the focus the
five percent we disagree on to it to the
point where we end up just like losing
and and it's completely
counterproductive and I think some of
the stuff you're talking about is under
that umbrella uh-huh what do you I'm
curious what are you thinking general do
you have you read even much into the TPP
do you have a strong opinion on it er
well listen I mean so since it died I
stopped following it altogether but my
basic view was like I can find certain
things in it that would arguably be like
incremental improvements over what we
have now but like I just have a real
problem with and I know that these exist
outside of the TPP framework but I think
corporations have too much power and
they exist outside of the judicial
system already too much so you know that
mechanism that the TPP included that
multinationals could basically you know
be an arbitration outside of the laws of
any individual country is sort of that
like I saw a little bit of Bernie on
Rogan yesterday and when roadman asked
him like why is this stuff legal and
Rogan said well because they made the
laws I just have a huge problem with
that but that doesn't merely what I mean
like this is one way to look at it but
it has to be that way right like I would
never if I'm accusing a country of
making unfair practices that are making
my firm uncompetitive I don't want their
that country's courts to determine
whether I would or lose my days right
like there's a reason why people always
resort to this third-party arbitration
in so in thousands of other bilateral
trade agreements and other trade
agreements around the world a lot of
mucha America is already a part to you
like I don't want to sue a company in
Canada or even the Government of Canada
because I think that they're
implementing some unfair labor practice
that's [ __ ] just my firm over and
then their courts decide who wins it
loses that deal that's like a horrible
deal for me okay but hold on so that's
the most charitable possible
interpretation of why those arbitration
things are good if we step back from
like that that particular thing
in most cases those types of barbra
arbitration things are significantly to
the advantage of the party that's most
in place to impose it so if you look at
like in the workplace if you look at
when it comes to environmental stuff
whoever wants that system is gonna be
disproportionately benefiting from it at
the expense of the other party so I
don't know that I would guess panels let
both people nominate a judge and then
they both have to agree on a third panel
person it's not like it's not like the
person bringing suit picks three friends
to come over and evaluate whether or not
they win or lose no it's not but you I
mean I'm sure that you would grant that
these systems are subject to the same
type of regulatory capture that like
basically every yeah it's the regulator
it's industry regulating the regulators
and that's the same problem we have in
the United States where you know it's
it's like capitalism for the gain for
the profits and social is socializing
the the costs and it's just hard for me
to say that I have no good reason to
think that they're proposing that in
good faith I mean I I just I mean I can
see where it might not be perfect but I
just can't think of like if I let's say
that I have a firm and another country
passes a law that I think is hurting my
firm yeah who should arbitrate this if
not like a third party panel like who
well should that won't that you would
only ask the question that way if you
were already completely bought into the
status quo of the multinational
corporation there's another way that
this stuff can work which is the same
stuff that makes it so that you have to
figure that at that situation out is the
one that allows a company that basically
is an American company to on paper be
Irish and then not pay any taxes in the
United States and the answer is you you
stop that infrastructure a company has
to be for youth you don't have
multinational companies that we do have
a multinational companies but you
regulate their activity their behavior
within countries based on the laws of
those countries I'm not saying that it
would be an easy thing to do but it's
just like you have to that's a paradigm
shift Flom though what do you do when a
country passes a law just to make your
firm non-competitive a country okay so
like what would be an example of that
um sure so we can use like a real-life
example in Canada there was a foreign
company that had a guess like that sold
gas there called ethyl Corp and Canada
passed a law that banned a certain
additive to fuel and only impacted this
company didn't impact any of the other
companies in Canada well I think if I
think this is [ __ ] and they're only
passing it to make me non-competitive if
not third-party arbitration who should I
appeal to their I mean okay so this I'm
that gets us to like a much broader
argument of like what are the rights
that a company should have like isn't
that some there would be people who
would say that's the prerogative of
Canada you you have no right to sell
your gas in Canada and if that's what
Canada decides then what why I mean that
that's totally their right like that's
not necessarily my position but that is
a position that's that's not a trade
position then then you're saying like
don't have trade deals because like the
natural extension of where that gets us
then is okay well if your country I
assume is about legal system I'm never
investing in your country ever I'm never
gonna start a business there and screw
you guys or if you want to open up trade
to another country well why would I open
up trade with your country if any time a
firm for my country tries to sell in
your country you make them
non-competitive with your local
legislation but you're sort of moving
the goalposts though because you first
started with like the specific
arbitration moulting you know a
superseding arbitration infrastructure
for TPP but now you're just saying like
what if any country does something
that's bad for my business so it's like
that that is a moving the goalposts of
sorts wait that but that's the that's
the fundamental question I don't think
it's moving the cabal's the fundamental
question is if I have a firm and I
wanted to be competitive with firms in
another country that we're supposed to
have open trade with what do I do if
that country is engaging in
discriminatory business practices that
favor their local companies over a
foreign one
so this is I think the strongest thing
which is if you have specific if you
have a particular agreement and
expectations that are part of a trade
deal then the question is how do you
enforce that and I completely agree that
you need to have some mechanism for that
my skepticism of the overarching way
that TPP had it and again I feel like
it's just semi moot because it's dead
but part of the problem with it was that
it didn't seem like it was the narrowest
way to address that particular issue
okay I I would be super curious and
hearing alternatives this seemed like a
good standard for resolving these
disputes that essentially like I'm gonna
sue you
so what we're both gonna do is we're
both gonna find our expert who's gonna
rule on this and then both of us are
going to agree on a third person or if
we can't then our two people are going
to agree on a third person yeah and then
we're gonna and then they're going to
evaluate who's in the right here and you
need two votes to win your case so not
only that seems like a good way to
resolve disputes using third-party
arbitration between a firm in another
country I get it I think the issue I'm
having is that TPP in total was such a
hand out to multinational corporations
which already control like all aspects
of everyone's lives period and are
raping and pillaging the resources of
the planet that it feels to me like wait
it wait a second are we gonna just
default to giving these corporations
everything they want I think that well I
mean like of course if we're in a
capitalist framework and we are doing
anything to improve the status of an
economy which is what multilateral trade
agreements are for these are by
definition going to benefit the largest
players in your country that's just a
that's just a reality right now if you
want to say something like corporations
have too much power or inequality is too
high I can I agree with both of those
statements obviously but you don't
address this with trade policy you
address this with with a domestic policy
right hold on a second but I don't know
that that's so hot let's back up for a
second though because if you when I step
back it's like okay TPP was going to
significantly strengthen patent and
copyright law to the benefit of huge
corporations at the expense of the
average person it was going to create
again this like extrajudicial
infrastructure for corporations that
even if you're making some reasonable
points about the need for a system like
it it's yet another letting the
companies figure out how they're going
to be regulated like when you step back
it's just letting big corporations tell
us how it is that they want to be
regulated and what it is that they want
to do and that I think is like the
fundamental problem I mean like I can
understand but like you're presenting
this with only one side like the other
side of this is that copyright
protections as much as we hate them on
the Internet are actually pretty
important to doing business if you're
going to invest a great deal of a
research and development of
you want to be able to exclusively
capture revenue through selling that for
some period of time one of the huge
problems that we talk about right now
but I think people I hope on the left
and right agree is that if you set up a
firm in some countries those countries
will make your firm transfer
intellectual property to other people
either to the state itself like in China
or to other competing firms and it's
like well [ __ ] well why would I ever
invest why I'm never going to set up a
company there if any software I transfer
or any proprietary knowledge is going to
be literally expropriated by the state
and then distributed to other companies
like I'm never gonna do that it's just
horrible so like I mean like this is one
of our huge critiques that we have with
China and it's arguably something that
the TPP would have given us a little bit
of leverage on that that another company
like a Chinese company couldn't do this
in another country that they're
operating in with an American firm
because now we can use the TPP to bring
suit against them or something yeah I
mean like the the copyright stuff maybe
goes too far but this is more of a
broader critique on copyright law not on
the TPP because well let me let me quote
an expert on trade named Donald Trump
okay once said we don't want to take a
hammer when a velvet glove would work or
something like that and and I'm sort of
joking because Trump's not an expert on
trade but what I mean is I think that
all of the issues that you're bringing
up could be dealt with in far more
narrow ways than the way that the TPP
was doing it and I am not grieving the
death of TPP okay I I mean I'd be
interested in hearing those it's usually
I just hear usually all of the
accusations just sounds to me like
somebody's like corporation bad and then
like that's like the default like no no
no do with it
I am I am I am NOT an anti capitalist I
am a social democrat and I am completely
clear on there are certain types of
advancements that you need the
infrastructure of a corporation to most
effectively kind of like carry the risk
and bear the research and development
costs in connection with obviously the
Commons and the fact that a lot of the
people making those advancements had
public school education like okay I'm
tempering it with social democracy so
I'm not like an anti corporate guy it I
just think that again there are far more
even with like copyright you can't even
say here's the way to deal with
copyright
patents dealing with it in entertainment
media versus pharmaceutical patents like
they need to be dealt with differently
in their different solutions in each
yeah I don't necessarily disagree I just
I mean it's just it's crazy to me that
if you have like a massive agreement
that we all agree provide some benefits
that like a few critiques of different
things within this agreement let you
scrap the whole thing like that's just
like yeah like it would be like car
shopping and you go through and you find
a perfect car good gas mileage a lot of
power a lot of space yeah I don't really
like the seats and I think we could just
do way better on that so screw this
whole vehicle it's like that's how I
shop for cars as soon as the seats are
comfortable I'm looking at a different
dealership I mean that makes it okay but
like if at the end of the day if you're
walking to work every day it seems like
you kind of shot yourself in the foot by
being too extremely
I don't maybe I'm too incrementalist am
i approach to a lot of these deals but I
don't know I mean I I mean I understand
what you're saying is crazy it's just
like I think that there are narrower
ways to deal with each of the things
that you like about TPP individually
that would not create I mean the other
thing is once you get into something
like TPP it's sort of like the tariffs
that Trump has put in place the off-ramp
is extraordinarily long and difficult so
for me wrapping so much stuff into one
deal in this way especially when so much
of it is questionable when we could deal
with all of these things individually
doesn't seem like the wisest path
forward well but I mean these trade
agreements are usually huge the European
Union is huge NAFTA is here's like these
these trade agreements are always going
to be massive because there's so much
there's so many side agreements that you
have to make but have to address
specific policies in every country and
it just seems like by walking away from
it America basically just said screw it
we're losing all of that influence in
the in the southeast Pacific region like
we just we don't have it anymore and now
China does because we walked away from
it the cut the ten remaining countries
signed on to it yeah with Japan leading
them and now China is moving through
with their initiatives to build out all
of their infrastructure across all of
Asia and Africa and we're just like
sitting here like twiddling our thumbs
getting into trade Wars and and yeah
locking ourselves in a box I completely
agree with you Russia now I mean Russia
that the Russia China us sort of like
superpower dynamics have gone
dramatically out of the us's favour now
you've got Russia making deals with
China for enter
harvesting you've got China going to
India for I don't remember if it's like
aluminum or steel because of the tariffs
I mean it's like everybody's basically
fine other than us as a result of this
yeah because those countries are not
ignoring like the globalist reality that
we're facing and a faster you globalized
and the bigger foothold you get in a
global market like the stronger your
countries gonna be China absolutely
understands that but then it seems like
we're scared in the West because of dumb
[ __ ] going on you've got like the United
Kingdom leaving the largest unified
market in the world
you've got the United States on
ironically engaging in trade wars the
largest trading partner that is actually
damaging not only our markets but our
job markets as well in the United States
like it's insane to me that people are
like all of a sudden we became
isolationist in like ten years I have no
idea what happened it's crazy hey is
this like what twitch is all about where
we just randomly argue about stuff oh
yeah sure yeah I scream for ten hours
I'll talk about a lot of random [ __ ] but
I'm sorry wow this is crazy well listen
I I'm slowly learning what I'm doing on
Twitch and one of the things I saw is
that your channel is like at the top
refer to mine so like that's good right
I'm a big twitch streamer okay I might
be a little boy on YouTube but I'm a big
guy here on Twitch right you're you're
doing well on YouTube as well I'm doing
okay yeah yeah alright I gotta like take
phone calls from my audience and stuff
yeah all right well hey have fun thanks
for conversation all right yep sounds
good I'll talk to you soon